petite vidéo en direct des entrepôts au
carrefour Allonnes
où vous pouvez le voir
on jette de la nourriture
à un niveau industriel
suite au mouvement de grève
plutôt que de donner des produits
à date courte aux salariés
la direction a choisi
de tout bazarder il faut savoir qu'on
est aujourd'hui le 3 mai
les produits sont bons
yes
sur la majorité de femmes je peux comme
en réjouir non monsieur non non vous
allez pas vous coller au plateau c'est
pas vrai oh mais sérieusement
oh là là oh là là c'est la honte c'est
une honte monsieur vous prenez en otage
une émission démocratique le peuple a
voté aujourd'hui et vous venez coller
votre main sur ce plateau c'est une
honte je refuse de coanimer cette
émission avec vous c'est une honte
dilatée comme jamais dilaté comme jamais
dit la tête comme jamais dilaté comme
jamais dit la terre comme jamais dilaté
comme jamais je ne vous donnerai pas la
parole vous l'avez strictement rien à
dire et je demanderai maintenant que
vous soyez évacué il s'est collé la main
avec de la colle
on va on va
quel après-midi bon